so yeah Jesse Jesse's in some trouble
and yesterday was a slow news day so
everybody was covering this everybody it
was ever and and and not only did the
Asian groups get upset sure but you know
people love outrage on Twitter and this
peak especially when it's on Fox News
like when people on Twitter realize
there is something that could be racist
on Fox News they go nuts you wanna see
the rest of it the clip got a lot of
thumbing yeah a lot of people came to
look just be mad at the clip yeah they
did yeah but it's got almost 800,000
views now yeah that's a lot of views you
know I don't know let's listen to this
Asian guy all right let's your friend of
me Brendan do you have any traditional
Chinese herbs for performance it's an
addictive it is a good sir my parents
about that I meant on television oh okay
okay we caught it barriers see now he's
making the people in Chinatown right now
he's practicing karate in a dojo
they marry playing with nunchucks do you
guys like to party yes the night we go
to party oh that's the spot okay now
he's getting his feet massaged dancing
can you play this little piggy went to
market this is my world
the is a guy legal Hanoi Shi you gotta
say it right Peter don't say it
Nico Nico not Japanese Chinese you got
dual properly okay teach otherwise
forget it new your high war goal guess
like I guess I got that's it Jake it's
Chinatown
I said that when you brought up the
subject as a joke like forget it
Sam it's Chinatown I kept myself back
because you knew it was like that's not
the reference it's still right yeah yeah
first came up you didn't like the jokes
in that one
they were [ __ ] horrible yeah yeah and
it's all the punchlines are just the
clips just the clips from movies just
responding like but not responding like
you imagine being an actor they're just
using your stuff like that yeah I'd be
so like asking Chinese questions it's
fine
that's acceptable or a guy in Chinese
but having a guy throw karate punches at
you is just stupid it's like what are
you doing
yeah getting your feet massaged and
asking her do you know you know little
pig or whatever that is
when you were first starting my boxing
name snortin or yeah my gym snore in
Norton being the ring throw my particle
I did a little piggys joke it was really
not good what was that what was the joke
how early into your career wasn't 17
years okay that's not and what was the
joke I forget I'd tell me this little
this little piggy went to market he was
a compulsive shopper no and then the
agoraphobic stay at home and the
compulsive overeater had roast beef and
a little bulimic had none and then there
was the pig us that when we lately all
the way home you did that whole thing I
did on stage that must have taken like
two minutes it was not good that's a
long bad joke it was it's a very long
joke with zero laughs in it
I will eventually stop with the car
crashes I'm sorry and also I think Jesse
Watters thrown some car crashes and for
him was not a bad I know I need some
more sound clips like why the car
crashes go away I don't think there's
ever a conscious decision it just went
away we're gonna do you want you can't
just ask for general so I gotta just
create some like thing creates them like
I think what want one that the fans
would love is if there's a big problem
if we had a sound effect that's it
what's the hullabaloo when you just you
just did it you just you've already
you've already got that on tape now yeah
but I won't get the magic of that back
well we have it on tape I know what I
want
you don't need you could just do that so
you you want a sound effects Board of
sounds that you make who doesn't you are
you already make the saddle oh wait I
know one he made those car crash noises
initially Wow you want that as a button
yeah why don't you just do it yeah busy
you're not beating must be rude for him
to make that noise if the guest is in
here don't thing but but if it comes in
as a you just hit the button I don't
know
sound effects somebody did that yeah no
is Travis or my iPad yeah yeah coming
for all the sound effects come from the
Tefft box so I don't know I don't know
what anything is yeah I really need to
get some more sound I only have to hear
I'm against the idea of you having sound
effects that are just you that doesn't
make any sense what the car crash car
crashing you're thought besmirching me